muy buenos días muchas gracias por esta
oportunidad siempre generará posiciones
y puntos de vista contradictorios sin
embargo yo creo que el aporte de julian
assange y sobre todo de wikileaks ha
sido muy importante en el mundo sobre
todo en el ejercicio del periodismo de
investigación uno de los puntos más
controvertidos dentro de la pulsación
que realiza eeuu en contra las farc ha
sido precisamente que ha puesto en
peligro vidas humanas porque la
revelación de determinados datos de
carácter informativo sin embargo esto no
ha sido demostrado me imagino que ya en
estos días dentro los bienes intentarán
hacerlo pero las primeras audiencias
preparatorias jamás ha sido demostrado
esta situación yo creo que hay un antes
y un después después de la apertura y
sobre todo de la difusión de los cables
informáticos a través de portal
wikileaks y definitivamente ha sido una
apertura frente a las situaciones que
todo el mundo desconocía precisamente en
estos momentos se revelan las
intenciones de varios estados de acallar
a varios periodistas sobre todo de
investigación y yo creo que este es un
icono de libertad y sobre todo ejercicio
de tradición también marcaría una
censura en contra de miles de
periodistas que elaboran en el mundo
señor poveda usted considera
julian assange es extraditado a eeuu o
va a tener allí un juicio justo bajo qué
argumento están diciendo ustedes que la
solicitud de extradición no es
justificable
precisamente desde el momento en que se
concede el asilo de vida de expectativas
y sobre todo había este tipo de
situaciones de inferencia de que no me
iba a existir de ninguna manera un
juicio justo desde la formación del
jurado en un estado en donde
precisamente no garantice a ningún tipo
de imparcialidad la conformación de
estos organismos jurisdiccionales sobre
todo inclusive miren lo que está pasando
en este momento a pocas horas de que se
lleve a la audiencia de tradición se
reemplaza a la orden nuestra adicción y
esto cambia enormemente a los medios de
prueba tengo entendido que el día de hoy
en la mañana si no hay una nueva orden
judicial situación que no fue discutida
del señor assange con los abogados de la
defensa británica y está indudablemente
no demostrar que no haber un juicio
justo de que posiblemente posible se le
condene a más de 175 años de privación
de libertad y en definitiva inclusive el
acceso a la defensa sería bastante
limitado precisamente el reino unido-
los abogados británicos algún manifiesto
ha manifestado sobre todo de que no ha
habido un acceso a una igualdad de armas
de defensa legal y esto imposibilita
juicio justo desde nuestra visión y peor
aún si es que se extradita dos estados
justamente esa era mi siguiente pregunta
y es las denuncias que hay de que hace
al menos seis meses que no tienen
contacto con assange como ven ustedes
desde la defensa
estas posibilidades y que prevé usted
para la audiencia que se lleva a cabo el
día de hoy
tengo entendido que una hora de la
mañana inclusive no fueron aceptados
para ingresar ni siquiera vía telemática
varias organizaciones de observadores de
carácter legal como los delegados de
amnistía internacional entendemos el
tema de la pandemia la crisis sanitaria
pero eso no era imposibilidad para que
puedan tener un acceso directo a la
audiencia de extradición esto ya nos
hace prever lo que podría ocurrir
esperamos de que se actúe conforme a
derecho' justicia sobre todo en el
respeto a normas internacionales de
derechos humanos y esto precisamente lo
que limita es de que la ciudadanía
conozca qué es lo que ocurre al interior
conozca los que habían manifestado que
son 18 en total no ha sido posible la
defensa que tenga un acceso directo al
señor lasa ya que se tenía que coordinar
la defensa y básicamente ha sido como
seis o siete meses sin contacto debido
sin el tiempo oportuno y sobre todo que
se le entregó una orden judicial de
reemplazo de esta edición esto
imposibilita enormemente la defensa y
las garantías para evitar la expedición
así eeuu
carlos poveda moreno abogado defensor de
julian assange en ecuador gracias a
ustedes por estar con nosotros